aquí también hay algo para moverse
Así que ahí cuando a veces queremos bajar.
en el bunker y cosas cuando hay
no tiene electricidad así que
es así
entonces esa es mariame
y
pero siempre siguen siendo sus colegas
Aquí es donde ponemos los colchones.
Ahí lo quitamos, estamos limpiando todo.
soltamos todo lo que estaba tirando cuando
incluso escuchamos muchos disparos
fuego y eso a veces hacía que el
ventanas y les pregunté a los niños
ella me dice que no, no quieren
No me voy y mi esposa también quiere.
no nos vamos así que nos quedamos
para poder
ver al pequeño
hasta que realmente escuché el
ruido allí que no podía imaginar
ya que para mi fue
hermanos y hasta ahora creo que
es una guerra sin sentido cuando no tenemos
No hay suficientes argumentos, son los golpes de
puño es golpes físicos es
que se puede arreglar pero cuando estamos
inteligente cuando eres intelectual
para mi siempre hay otros
argumentos que se pueden utilizar sin
pasar por esto realmente es asesino
Esto es lo que tengo
y así es como
incluso dame mucho coraje para no hacerlo
ya viene no quedarse en casa
cuando ves que ayudaste a alguien
Subí al tren y ya es un
suspiro de alivio
con tacos
tú
gastado
en mi cabeza habia perdido el negocio
entonces vamos a hacer aún más negocios
Solo seré lo que intenté
mantener una conexión con los empleados
Habría sido para mí pero fuera de
cuestión de decirle a mis equipos que soy
en Francia sigues trabajando yo
Soy accesible pero permanezco en
Francia es simplemente no, es una elección.
adrede
asumir y
afirmar que algunas personas me tienen
en realidad lo dijiste pero no lo hiciste
Necesito estar allí si honestamente creo
Te necesito
Necesito porque hay podemos
hacer muchas cosas
No necesariamente necesitamos estar seguros
el frente para estar activo en el en el
guerra contra rusia
Esta es una foto del mes de
junio creo
Está tomado en Francia, de hecho lo hice.
varios ida y vuelta con un
furgoneta de la empresa para ir
busca torniquetes que todos estos son
torniquetes militares una guardia tónica
diferentes materiales de relieve allí
tenía extintores
allí
a ver si el dia la victoria sera
en un proclamado
[Música]